AccessAbility/VisAbility:
Breaking Down The Barriers
For People With
Disabilities In Media.
Please welcome Academy Governor,
and Oscar-winning actor,
Whoopi Goldberg.
[AUDIO DESCRIPTION]
Whoopi Goldberg
is a Black woman with shoulder
length black dreadlocks,
brown eyes, and is wearing
purple round glasses
and silver hoop earrings.
She is wearing a very
light lavender colored top
with white buttons
and a black necklace,
with blue and white beads.
And she is sitting
in a white chair
against a textured background.
Hey, I'm Whoopi
Goldberg and I am
proud to be a Governor of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences, the Actors Branch.
2020 marks the 30th
anniversary of the Americans
with Disabilities Act.
It's a civil rights law,
prohibiting discrimination
against individuals with
disabilities in all life areas,
including jobs,
schools, transportation,
and public and
private places that
are open to the general public.
It guarantees equal
opportunity for all individuals
with disabilities, regardless
of race, color, sex,
national origin,
age and religion.
One in five Americans
have a disability,
making them a part of America's
largest minority group.
But not all disabilities
are immediately apparent.
In this program, we will
hear from an immensely
talented and diverse group of
industry professionals, actors
and managers, directors,
sound designers, VFX artists,
animators, all who happen
to have a disability.
So thank you to all
our panelists and a big
thank you to the Ruderman
Family Foundation
for the grant which makes
this program possible.
I think you'll agree, yes,
we can always do better.
But we hope these discussions
will help educate and highlight
the importance and
advantages of hiring people
with disabilities, whether
it be in front of the camera,
or behind the scenes.
Please welcome our host,
Oscar-winning actor,
Marlee Matlin, and
interpreter, Jack Jason.
[AUDIO DESCRIPTION]
Marlee Matlin
is a white woman with
below the shoulder
length blonde hair
and blue eyes.
She is wearing a solid white
top, gold hoop earrings,
and a gold necklace.
She is sitting in a multicolored
chair in an office space
in front of a large
blue and white painting,
some photographs,
her Oscar statuette
and white and yellow roses.
While a rarity in
motion pictures,
authentic disability
representation
can be traced back
to the silent era.
Films including, You'd Be
Surprised in 1926, The Best
Years of Our Lives in 1946,
Children of a Lesser God,
1986, When I Walk, in
2013, The Writer in 2017,
The Silent Child in 2017,
A Quiet Place in 2018,
Give Me Liberty in 2019,
and The Peanut Butter
Falcon in 2019, featured
lived disability experiences.
Let's hear from actor Danny
Woodburn, and actor comedian,
Maysoon Zayid, and talent
manager, Eryn Brown,
about authentic
representation, why it matters
and how far we have come.
[AUDIO DESCRIPTION] Authentic
Representation: Why It Matters
And How Far We Have Come,
with actor Danny Woodburn,
actor and comedian, Maysoon
Zayid, and talent manager Eryn
Brown.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Danny Woodburn, actor,
comedian, and activist.
I'm a white male
man with dwarfism.
I am wearing a blue
shirt, I had to look.
I'm wearing a blue
shirt, blue suspenders,
I have a full beard, and the
hairline of a cruise ship
captain.
Before we get started,
it's my pleasure
to welcome Amanda Grazian, who
will be our ASL interpreter
for this discussion.
I am a Caucasian female with
shoulder length brown hair,
blue eyes, and a
black suit jacket.
Thank you for being here.
Next, we have my friend,
comedian, actor, writer,
Maysoon Zayid.
As a comedian, Maysoon
has toured extensively
at home and abroad.
She had the most viewed
Ted Talk of 2014,
and is the author of
a best selling memoir,
Find Another Dream.
She appeared alongside
Adam Sandler,
in the movie, one
of my favorites,
You Don't Mess with the Zohan.
And is a recurring character
on "General Hospital",
who I believe has not been
slapped in the face yet.
Thank you for that
stellar introduction.
I want to describe
myself to the audience.
I look like the lost Kardashian.
I have cinnamon skin,
long black hair,
and I'm wearing a Prince
Purple Rain Calvin Klein
suit, with a black and
blue sparkly shirt.
Next up we have talent
manager, Eryn Brown.
Eryn, is partner
at Management 360,
and has guided the careers of
critically acclaimed artists,
such as Academy Award-winner,
Sebastian Lelio of A Fantastic
Woman, Pablo Larrain of Jackie,
Phil Johnston of Wreck-It Ralph
and Zootopia, and Cate
Shortland of Black Widow.
My name is Eryn Brown.
I am a 46-year-old white
woman with light brown hair.
I was born with an
undiagnosed muscular myopathy.
I'm wearing a blue
and white pinstripe
shirt with a ruffled color
and a bubblegum pink cardigan.
Behind me, over
my right shoulder
is wallpaper with blue
and pink palm fronds,
and over my left shoulder is
a glass wall with more palms.
I didn't get as descriptive
with my clothing as you are you
guys did.
But anyway, welcome to you both.
We have a very interesting
panel, the panel,
let's call it this: Authentic
Representation: Why It Matters
And How Far We Have Come.
why it matters, and
how far we have come.
So the obvious first question
is, why does it matter
and how far have we come?
We hear the hashtag all the
time, representation matters,
but I want to talk about
why it actually matters.
People with disabilities
are 20% at least, maybe
25% of the population.
But we're only 2% of the
images you see on TV.
And 95% of those images are
non disabled performers.
The message being sent
out to disabled kids
is, you do not
belong in this world.
It is a very, very
dangerous message.
It adds to the stigma
against visible disabilities
and invisible disabilities.
Because we actually have
no idea how many people
with invisible disabilities
grace our screens,
because the stigma is so strong,
that even celebrities feel
fear revealing that they're part
of the disability community.
So one of the reasons
I think it matters,
is because people
with disabilities
face enormous amounts of
bullying, of violence,
and of discrimination.
And I believe that positive
images of disability,
in both fiction and nonfiction
can help stop the violence
that we as a community face.
My personal feeling is
that, in the last five years
I have felt an exponential shift
compared to the previous 20.
I don't know.
Do you guys feel
the same way that--
I feel like we're
in so much trouble
and that's gotten so much worse.
So you are as you said, the
voice of doom, but I think--
I'm the goddess of
darkness, but what
I do see of disability on
screen, is mostly white men.
So that's not really feeling
very representative to me,
as a woman of color,
or someone you
know who works in
the intersectionality
of the community.
I think that the images
that we are seeing
are still too infantilized,
too much inspiration porn.
And I know, I know that
the stories are not
being told by us.
I still feel like
anytime I enter
a room, a studio, or a set,
I'm the only disabled person.
It's daunting being the
only disabled person,
and I don't really feel
like we've made progress
until big stars finally say no
to playing disabled on screen,
if they are not
disabled in real life.
Once we have people
saying no to that,
then I'll think
we've moved forward.
Eryn, do you feel
like as a person that
works with creatives, as
a person who essentially
is connecting to
decision makers, right?
Writers, producers, do you
feel like there is a shift
or how do you feel about where
we are, where we've come from?
I guess I have to
agree with Maysoon,
I've never seen
myself on television.
And the great
surprise for me was
that I didn't realize
that I had never
seen myself on TV, until
a couple of years ago
when a colleague took me to
the premiere of his client's,
"Special", which is a wonderful
series written and created
and starring Ryan O'Connell.
And it was the first time
that I saw a disabled person
just existing in their life, and
doing normal things like dating
and having fights with
their friends and squabbles
with their parents.
And I'm not young.
I'm not a man, and
I'm not gay, but that
was the first time
I felt like I'd even
seen a shred of something
that I related to.
Do you feel like you have
any influence over the talent
that you represent, like, just
your mere presence or them
connecting to you on
a different level?
Has a writer ever come to
you and said, look, I'm
writing this story, what
do you think of this?
They ask your opinion.
There's not other disabled
writers in the room.
Will they ask your opinion
as maybe their only resource?
No, they haven't.
I do feel that I have
a lot of influence,
and I take very seriously the
responsibility, my contribution
to the culture
that I help create
through the work of my clients.
But the stigma of disability
is so strong and so shameful
that there has been a lack
of discourse about it,
even between me
and my own clients,
because as I do gently try to
explore that and suggest when
people are talking about
LGBTQ, or BIPOC characters,
I'll say, what about
someone in a wheelchair?
But it's a fine line.
I don't want anyone
to think that I'm
servicing a particular
agenda or one of my own.
Right.
Well, for me growing up, I
know you said you don't really
see yourself represented.
And the times that
I did see myself,
I grew up in the
'70s predominantly,
it's where I think, the
formative years occurred for me
and seeing somebody like Michael
Dunn, who was a little person
actor, or Billy Barty on screen.
A lot of times it
came with pathos.
It filled in a lot of
the blanks for the tropes
around disability.
The sad little man, or
the devious little man,
or something like that.
I don't know that there
were very many positives.
I appreciated
their performances.
I appreciated what they
were able to do as actors,
but a lot of times the
storylines were the same.
I connected more to somebody
like Sydney Poitier,
who for me was like
a powerful influence
on, in my sense, what it
meant to be accepted as a man.
I think that really is
like a big reality that
still remains prevalent.
Is that like disabled
people only get three
storylines, right?
You can't love me because I'm
disabled, heal me or kill me.
I grew up seeing a lot
of disabled stories
where families were better off
when the disabled person died.
Or I saw a lot of disabled
people being healed.
And I always talk about
this one image that
stuck with me
forever, was there was
a blind character on "Little
House on the Prairie",
and he got caught
in an explosion,
and he got his vision back.
And like, I'm really glad I
didn't blow myself up as a kid,
trying to heal myself.
Like these things
are really dangerous
and we're just like
inundated with these images
that we either have
to be charity cases
where you get a blanket if
you give us money or kill us
and your life will be better.
And I think we're still living
in those three stories, which
is why I really do enjoy working
with both Eryn and Danny,
because I think we really are
fighting for those mainstream
images.
Like Danny said, he was
influenced by Sidney Poitier.
I was influenced
by Dolly Parton.
And like the fact that she is
not disabled never occurred
to me, it was like, that
was the kind of entertainer
I wanted to be.
And I pursued it, and I
managed to navigate that world
by going through comedy,
because I did not
see people who looked
like me on television,
except in the world of comedy.
Because comedy is like
the home of misfits.
Right.
In my comedy career,
was basically
I was told from early on,
you just do short jokes.
It was never about addressing
the way society has
been looking at me and how
it's been wrong, but how I
should look at myself as wrong.
So in my comedy, I flipped that.
That's the challenge that
we have to dismantle.
Is that the content
that's been made
suggests that we
are the problem.
And when you internalize
that from a very young age,
why would I bring it up to
people, whether it's my clients
or otherwise, because I am
the problem in the world.
The world isn't the
problem, it's me.
We've tried everything.
We've tried shaming actors
into not playing disabled
if they're not disabled.
We've tried showing
our buying power.
We've shown that
we have the talent.
We've shown that any project
we do ends up being successful.
It's not working.
I've been doing it for 20 years.
And disabled people are
still being shunned.
We're not allowed
to tell our stories,
and we're simply not
included even close
to the level that we need to be.
So I wish I had some positive
story about never giving
up and creating your own
stuff, but I don't know.
I think it has to be something
where the unions demand
equal representation,
and that if projects
aren't inclusive, and
aren't accessible,
then they don't get the status
that they need to go forward.
It has to be like legislated
for it to actually happen.
I don't think just trying to
convince Hollywood to give us
a chance has worked
in the past 50 years,
and it doesn't look like
it's going to change
unless it's forced to.
We still have such
an uphill battle
because for the longest
time as you both know,
I'm sure we have not been
included in the diversity
discussion.
And then when we do make a
little headway, for example,
what the Academy
put out recently
with regard to
nomination requirements,
there is tremendous pushback
from supposed progressives
who see this as a
slight to the art.
And they make these comments
without a full understanding
of the scope of what has
gone on for years, and years,
and years, and what
continues to go on unchanged.
And art is supposed to be
all inclusive, is it not?
And they don't have that
understanding of that part
of the conversation.
I think there's so
many layers to it
and I think a raised
awareness in this moment
of cultural reckoning
is really imperative,
and a pointing out,
include disability
in the conversation when there
are conversations about LGBTQ
and BIPOC that disability is a
category, that is automatically
discussed.
So it becomes normalized.
And then I think
that there will have
to be something that's
a big disruptor.
I agree with Maysoon, and I
don't know if it's legislation
or certain companies decide
that they want to support,
and they want to get behind
a movement that says,
not only this is the right thing
to do, but it's good business.
Good business.
It has really positive
cultural ramifications
and it's opportunity for
an intersectional movement
because disability affects every
group and anyone at any moment
can become disabled.
So it's in everyone's best
interest for the world
to be accommodating.
Adam Sandler told me
the best thing ever,
because I know it's really
hard for disabled people
to ask for accommodations.
You finally make it
through the door,
and the last thing you
want to do is be a burden,
delay any shooting.
And I was having trouble getting
in and out of my trailer.
So I was basically
jumping into a PA's arms.
And Adam Sandler saw me, and he
was like, "What is happening?
Make her trailer accessible."
And I said to him,
I really didn't
want to be high maintenance.
And he said, look around,
we were in Hollywood,
I was on the set
with Mariah Carey,
I was not the person who
was high maintenance.
So we have to get
rid of that fear
of asking but also
understand that we
will be met with resistance.
So even though it's
not our job, it's
good when you're asking
for accommodations
to know what the solution is.
Even better, it shouldn't
be your responsibility
to ask for accommodations.
It should be part
of the contract,
and part of the line producer,
and a part of the production,
where they ask you, what
do you need to do your job?
Right.
It's just not--
I think it's also
has to do with how --
forget the stigma
around disability.
There's a stigma around actors.
Right?
I think we need a
disabled Disney princess.
So we do have one Disney
disability icon, Nemo.
He's got the bum fin.
And there's-- a belief that
Lilo & Stitch is also a disabled
story.
I think it'd be really helpful
to have a disabled princess.
I want to end on
a positive note,
because I was like
so doom and gloom.
A lot of disabled
people are putting out
a lot of fantastic work.
It's amazing.
Danny and I are
producing this show.
And the number of new
talent applications we got
was astounding.
And the amount of
just pure talent
in this community
that exists is ready
for their close-uo
is really inspiring.
I'm seeing disabled people
in every area excelling.
We just need to make
sure they get the chance.
It's not a lack of talented
disabled people in the world,
it's just the lack of the
ability to showcase it.
And I think too.
The people that we get
that have the talent,
I think the powers that
be have to recognize,
they fought harder for their
education than anybody else.
And they did all that they
could to learn their craft
and be exceptional.
And so I feel like that--- we
had to go that extra mile that
a non disabled person
doesn't have to go,
to get to that place of being
accepted as a viable talent.
That, I think
should be something
on the minds of people in
the position of casting
or producing a project.
That they go, oh,
this person really
has come a long way to
get to this spot, where
I'm interested in
what they're doing.
And it's an unfortunate
reality that we
have to go that extra mile but
I think if they have a better
understanding that we've
gone the extra mile,
then we'll be in a place where
these panels are obsolete.
I don't want our
panels to be obsolete.
This is the most fun I've had
since the pandemic started.
I think that one thing that
would really change everything,
is if me and Danny
co-hosted the next Oscars.
That would be the
disability representation
that pushed everyone to have
equal disabled representation
on all their shows.
I think that's the key.
I couldn't have said a better
idea if I had a year and a half
to come up with it.
Brilliant idea.
I wonder who we could talk to?!
I wonder?!
I think it's
interesting to point out
that I think there have been
62 nominees for characters
with disability over
the Oscar's history.
There have been 27 winners of
that category for best actors
or supporting actor, actress.
But only two had
actual disability.
So what better way to
shift the paradigm,
than to have Maysoon
and I host the show.
I'll do your hair and makeup.
Oh, cool.
Awesome.
You know how to do
lost Kardashian?
I'll learn.
And cruise ship captain,
you know how to do that?
And cruise ship captain.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you, both so much.
I'm glad we could do it.
Thank you so much for having us.
And thanks to the Academy.
And now please welcome
back Marlee Matlin.
Not only do inclusion
riders call for diversity
in front of the
camera, but they also
strive for equity and
inclusivity behind the scenes.
Employers might be hesitant
to hire industry professionals
with disabilities because
of additional costs.
But incorporating
accessibility measures,
open up employers to a pool
of qualified applicants,
often overlooked in the past.
Filmmakers, Jenni Gold, Jim
LeBrecht, and visual effects
supervisor, Kaitlyn
Yang, have created
successful and
accessible businesses
for below the line
professionals with disabilities.
Let's hear from them
about their work,
behind the camera, why
inclusion benefits us all.
Behind The Camera: Why
Inclusion Benefits Us All.
With filmmakers, Jenni
Gold and Jim LeBrecht,
and VFX supervisor,
Kaitlyn Yang.
Hi, I'm Jenni Gold.
I have blonde hair
and brown eyes.
I'm wearing a red
shirt with a pattern
and I'm sitting in a power
wheelchair in my home theater.
You might know me best from the
film I produced and directed,
the award winning
star-studded CinemAbility:
the Art of Inclusion.
And now let me introduce
two good friends
and remarkable people.
First, the talented
James LeBrecht
who has more than 35
years of experience
as a film and theater
sound designer and mixer.
He is also a founder of
Berkeley Sound Artists,
an audio post-production
company and the co-director
and co-producer with Nicole
Newnham of the Netflix
documentary Crip Camp.
Hey, Jim, welcome.
Hi, Jenni.
Great to be here.
I am a older white
guy with a gray goatee
and kind of brownish long hair.
And I've got a blue
patterned shirt on.
I am in my home
office in Oakland.
There's a red wall behind
me with some posters on it.
And that about sums me up.
Now I have the pleasure of
introducing visual effects
supervisor Kaitlyn Yang, who is
the founder of Alpha Studios.
Kaitlyn has more than
50 credits to her name,
including Robot Chicken, Grey's
Anatomy, and Four Weddings
and a Funeral.
Thanks for joining us, Kaitlyn.
Hey, Jenni.
Hey, Jim.
Thank you for having me.
I am a Asian-American woman.
I am at my office with
white walls behind me
with some posters of
our most recent work.
And as always, I'm surrounded
by computers and monitors.
Thanks for joining us, Kaitlyn.
And welcome, everyone, as we
take a look behind the camera
to discuss why inclusion
benefits us all.
So let's discuss it.
Well, I think that the more
varied voices and experiences
that come into a team working
on a film, the greater
the possibility for bringing out
nuance in stories that really
paint a brighter picture
to what we're doing.
I think for me, you know,
right now in Hollywood,
we are not only craving
for ourselves to be seen.
But we're really craving stories
that we haven't heard before.
And I think one great
treasure trove of stories
that we haven't heard
before are from people
who are underrepresented,
especially
people with disabilities.
And I think it makes
for great storytelling.
It also makes great
business sense as well.
Right?
We kind of make
up 1/4 of America,
which is kind of
crazy if you think
about it, everyone
with a physical
or invisible disability.
And I think it's just
good business sense for us
to be included not only
in front of the camera,
but also behind the
camera so we can support
one another with the dollars
that we're essentially
voting whenever we're
going to support a movie.
How can we help other
professionals make sure
that when they're
hiring that they
look for qualified candidates
who might have disabilities?
I think in terms of
hiring, as we all know,
the world is really not
made for people like us.
If anything, we're
used to, as we're
using to adapting our
environment for it to work
for us, and that
transitions into so
many transferable skills
especially in the filmmaking
community.
A lot of times you have
to think on your toes
and come up with ideas and all
the good stuff that we are--
we've been essentially
doing our whole lives.
And I think for people
with disabilities,
we do have to work
way harder than others
to get a seat at the table.
I would say that the
entry into our business,
not only just
having a disability,
but it comes down to
unpaid internships.
There are plenty of people who
economically cannot do that.
And they are being filtered out.
And then when we look
at what qualifications
we're looking for people
or how people kind of get
into our business that we
have to kind of steer away
from this idea of the entry
level position of somebody
who is a production
assistant that
can carry 14 cups of
coffee onto the set
or that can work 20-hour days.
And in the past, I think
it's been traditional
that we think that if
you're not willing to put
in the long, long
hours and stuff,
then you really aren't
dedicated to working.
And that's simply not true.
Jim, I think you're hitting
so many great points there.
I think one of them is
we've been overlooked
for so long for a
lot of qualifications
that we've been doing.
As we navigate not only our
professional lives, but also
in our personal lives as
well, I like to joke and say
that we kind of show
up, and we kind of
do BYOC, bring our
own chairs, right?
And I think especially
for post-production,
you're looking for
talented people
to sit in front of a computer
all day problem solving.
And that is our strength.
You know, it's interesting.
I've come to realize
that my disability is
an advantage for me in my
career choice as a director.
You have to direct someone to
do what you want them to do,
which is part of the skill
that I use on set with actors.
I'm getting them to do what
I want them to do my way.
I grew up doing that.
And I think that a lot of people
do look at it as a negative,
but it can be a positive.
A phrase I hear a lot is I'm
a very precise communicator.
And I say all the
information up front
without you having to come back
and ask for clarifications.
And I do this because
once again, I have
been doing this my entire life.
The ways that we're
describing what we need to see
and the order that would be
most helpful for it to happen,
that, again, is one
of our strengths.
It's one of our expertise.
And I think a lot of times
precise communication equals
less communication.
And it saves more
money if you can
get someone who has a vision and
is very comfortable describing
that particular vision
to an entire team
like I do as a visual
effects supervisor.
Right?
That's my job on a daily basis.
That will benefit the
post-production team overall.
So Zoom is a big deal now.
Everyone is using
it for meetings,
and they're becoming more
comfortable with the idea.
How do you think that is
affecting your meetings
and your future
plans of continuing
to work with it or not?
So it's interesting
that you bring it up.
One of the silver linings
I have found during COVID
and taking a lot of meetings
via video conferencing
on Zoom or other
platforms is I'm
finding that video conferencing
is kind of taking away
the uncomfortableness that
a lot of people might have
if I were to take
the same meeting
and I would go
into the boardroom,
and I would roll
in, in my chair.
Now I feel like Zoom is kind of
putting us on an equal playing
field or getting closer to at
least where I can conference
in with someone and not
having to worry about, oh,
how do I address the
elephant in the room, right?
The odds might be already
against you before you even
show your ideas.
But I think now on Zoom, we
can just start with the ideas.
We can just start
with the deck, right?
I don't necessarily have to feel
and take a temperature poll of,
like, oh, how do people in
the Zoom call feel about--
Right.
--my wheelchair because
when I show up like this,
those questions kind of get
erased temporarily, you know?
I mean, I'll see kind of what--
if their attitude translates
to in person when we do meet.
But for now, Zoom
calls I think has
been a great tool of
this equalizer in a way.
Certainly starting out in my
audio post-production career,
it was always like that
elephant in the room.
I'm sitting in a wheelchair.
And it was only by having
years and years of experience
and building a reputation that
preceded me that I felt like I
could really relax about that.
When I first became a
member of the Academy,
I came down to Los Angeles.
And I wound up talking to
the head of Membership.
And I was asking about
disability and percentages
and stuff.
And she told me, you
know, Jim, people are not
willing to identify because
of the stigma of disability.
The fact of the matter
is in an ideal world,
if everybody revealed
or identified,
people in our
industry would realize
that we're everywhere really.
You can see me and
Jenni and Kaitlyn.
And yeah, you can tell that we
have some body jazz going on.
But there's so many
different people
who are right with you that
have to hide their disabilities.
I totally agree, Jim.
I think when Jenni and I first
connected many years ago,
we first became bonded because
we have the same disability.
We have spinal muscular atrophy.
And I thought,
wow, how cool is it
that I am seeing
someone else that
is representing me and
fighting the same battle?
I will just challenge
people and think about it.
It's kind of like people
wearing glasses, right?
Having that one tiny bit just
makes a world of difference.
Our chairs make that world
of difference for us.
For some other people, it might
be closed captioning, right?
Maybe they are hard of hearing
at certain times, right?
And that's helpful.
And having image
description, that's
also helpful for other people.
It's so common, and
yet it's something
that we're still not
sharing widely because it
carries a stigma, right?
I challenge you,
do you know anyone
who doesn't have anything?
Yeah.
It's nice to see that
people are starting
to be more open and interested
in the whole inclusion
discussions.
Do you think that the
industry could do more than
what it's doing currently?
Absolutely.
So I was bitten by
the visual effects
bug at a very young age.
Like most VFX people, I
was bitten by Star Wars.
And I was absolutely blown
away at all the visuals
I was seeing.
And I even remember
from many decades
ago when I was a
9-year-old, I was looking up
visual effects in these books.
And I couldn't find any
practitioners who were women.
So one of the questions I
carried with me for a long time
was, well, I hope
they're going to be OK
having women work in this
field, because this is what
I want to spend my life doing.
And seeing the
data now in 2020, I
think that is still a
legitimate question, right?
There are still no data, no
official data coming out.
But I did a quick data
gathering on LinkedIn.
And the stats are not great.
The stats I found is basically
0.001% of visual effects
supervisors that are women.
So we are still a
couple of digits
of becoming a whole number.
And if anyone else wants to
challenge me on those stats,
I welcome them to, right?
Because I would like
to know other women
supervisors as well.
I think you even beat
the female directors.
I think that's even
worse than the numbers--
Yeah, it's worse.
I didn't think
that was possible,
but I think you did it.
I started something called
the Gold Test, which
is similar to the Bechdel Test.
That is the test about it if
there's two females in a movie
and they talk to each
other about something other
than a man.
And most films don't
pass that simple test.
So I thought I would start
one called the Gold Test.
Is there a character
with a disability
in this fictional story that
is three-dimensional and not
defined by their disability?
To my surprise,
there wasn't anybody.
There wasn't anybody
in the film whatsoever
in these fictitious
worlds that we're seeing.
So my thought is, if you don't
exist in our worlds of fiction,
how do you exist in real life?
When you're going
out for that job,
how does that employer know to
hire you if they haven't even
seen you in works of fiction?
If we look at stereotypes
that we hold--
and we all hold
stereotypes about people.
And if we look at
what the stereotype is
of people with disabilities,
it's not really good.
But it is really our
industry's responsibility
to not only hire people
behind the scenes
or in front of the camera,
but to produce media embracing
that we are members of society
who are vibrant and add so much
and are incredibly capable.
You know, myself,
Jenni, and Jim,
we spend so much
of our time talking
about what makes us diverse
when if you think about it, what
makes us diverse, we
had no say in being born
with these disabilities, right?
An area that we
did have a say in
is the area that we
studied and we practice.
But we're still
not being brought
to the table for the area that
we spent many years studying.
We're still being brought
to the table saying,
oh, hey, let's talk about
what makes you diverse, right?
And I think we need to have
these conversations to get over
this hurdle to eventually
shift the focus on our work.
But I think this is
the start of that.
And I think with the climate of
all the other activism that's
going on right now, we really
need to harness this energy
and use it for good
and say, hey, it's
not OK that we're not even 1%.
You know, please help
us achieve parity.
What do you think that
the studios need to do?
The start of that is just
asking questions, right?
Asking thoughtful questions.
I had a producer once who hired
me to visual effects on set.
And they said, hey,
so this is going
to be my first time working with
someone in a wheelchair, right?
This is a new realm for me.
And I'm open to learning.
Can you tell me what
I can do to help?
Is there anything
you need, right?
How can I be a best support for
you to do your job well on set?
That's something I've
been wanting to say,
and I really love what you said.
If I'm going to hire somebody--
I'm non-disabled.
Instead of, like,
being on the negative,
like, well, just tell me
what you won't be able to do.
Tell me how I can--
is there anything I
can do to help you
do the best work that you can?
I don't think I said
that quite eloquently.
But you get the point.
And it's just-- it's
a different attitude.
None of us get to your door
with being oversensitive and mad
at everybody.
We've gotten to you
with being able to deal
with our disability.
And we are comfortable
So it's like, ask the question.
Let's just get it
taken care of--
and I can be the biggest help
that you're going to have.
Let's talk about
what advice you might
give to young people coming
into the business today.
I think there's kind of a
universal piece of advice
for just about any question.
And that is to find
your community.
And that is to find your tribe.
There are people like myself
and plenty of other people
that have already
been doing this work.
There is a group that I
helped found called FWD-Doc.
And it is a group of documentary
filmmakers with disabilities.
We have over 100 members now.
And I would say that if you
can't live without it, then
you gotta go and do it.
You know, I always said to
myself when I was little,
wouldn't it be
great if I can find
a female Asian-American
woman who
wants to go into visual
effects so I can figure out
how she's done it, you know?
And I hope that others
can take the lessons
I've learned along the way
to say that it is possible.
That's the beauty
of visual effects.
Anything is possible.
If they can make the
Millennium Falcon possible,
making ramps to make
other studios accessible
is also possible.
Don't give up.
It's wonderful that
kids today don't
have to be the pioneers that
maybe the three of us were.
The groundwork is laid.
Hopefully we've laid
some more today.
Thank you all.
This has been a wonderful
opportunity to chat.
So thank you guys
for joining us.
In an era of celebrating
intersectionality,
let's not exclude disability
from the conversation.
Persons with disabilities
make up more than 20%
of the world's population and
come from all backgrounds,
including various
ethnicities, genders, races,
and sexualities.
What we see in motion pictures
influences the way we interact
with the world around us?
In paving the way for a new
generation of storytellers,
let's create and promote stories
from all these intersecting
backgrounds by hiring talent
with lived experiences
to tell these stories.
For our last panel, let's
hear from animator, director,
writer Jorge Gutierrez and
actors Millicent Simmonds
and Zack Gottsagen.
Who will speak
about Hollywood's untapped
talent and unlimited potential.
Fresh Voices: Hollywood's
Untapped Talent and Unlimited
Potential with animation
director Jorge Gutierrez
and actors Millicent
Simmonds and Zack Gottsagen.
Hi, everyone.
I am Jorge Gutierrez.
I am the creator with my wife,
Sandra Equihua of a cartoon
called El Tigre.
I'm also the director and the
co-writer of a movie called
The Book of Life.
And currently I'm
writing and directing
a Netflix movie series
called Maya and the Three.
It's my pleasure to welcome
the very talented Millicent
Simmonds, the star
of Wonderstruck
and the blockbuster
A Quiet Place
and the forthcoming
A Quiet Place Part
II which looks so good.
Hi.
My name is Millicent
Simmonds, and I'm an actress.
Currently I'm sitting in
a room with a fireplace
and a TV mounted on the wall.
It's a bright, cheery room.
I'm wearing a black
long-sleeved turtleneck,
and my hair is pulled
back in a low bun.
I'm wearing a ring.
I'm a Caucasian 17-year-old
female who is profoundly deaf.
Thanks for joining us, Millie.
And lastly, another extremely
talented young performer
Zack Gottsagen is an
award-winning actor
and the star of the 2019 indie
hit The Peanut Butter Falcon,
which is amazing.
My name is Zachary Gottsagen.
And I am the actor.
And I'm fun and it's good to be
with my friends and my family.
Cool.
Thanks for joining us, Zack.
I forgot to do my
visual description.
I am a 45-year-old
lovably chubby Mexican man
with a black mustache
and a hat that
belonged to my grandfather.
Let's kick things
off with the title
of this discussion, Hollywood's
Untapped Talent and Unlimited
Potential.
What would you like to say to
our beloved industry and all
these producers and studio
heads and directors about people
like us that are a
little different,
but we have so
much more to offer?
The title of this
panel is so true.
We do have talent.
And we are proving it
time and time again.
And we have been
throughout history.
People with disabilities are
continuing to shock the world
and to change
people's perspectives
and open their
minds to diversity.
We are breaking through all of
these boundaries and barriers.
We are continuing to
educate people that --
we're changing so much.
There is no limit to
what we can do now.
That's wonderful.
Zack, do you want to chime in?
I would say I'm good and excited
and just to show I'm talented.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm on the autism spectrum.
You know, it's a thing
that early in my life
brought me some difficulties.
But it's actually
made me a lot more--
I would say it's
become my superpower.
And it's really allowed
me to be really,
really sort of focused in my job
and really sort of inquisitive
about the process.
So that thing that
as a kid I was told
was going to be a weakness has
turned out to be my strength.
What do you look
for when reading
a script for a new project?
Have you had to fight
to play a role intended
for a non-disabled person?
When I'm reading
through a script, what
I'm looking for is I have
to have that aha moment,
that moment when I feel
goosebumps or I feel
shocked because there is a twist
in the story or even a moment
where I feel I resonate
with a particular character.
I need to have that.
I need to have that
connection with the character
in order to immerse
myself in their world.
And it helps me develop my
own character in my way.
Now, I have had to compete
against non-disabled people
for particular roles.
I have had to audition.
And again, when I'm
looking for a role,
I try to find something
that might suit me.
I'm a young teenage girl, 17,
and there might be a great role
out there for me.
I'm not above calling
directors and producers,
suggesting they have a deaf
actress for a particular role.
I don't know why we
can't make changes
in scripts and in stories.
It makes things
more interesting.
On a side note, in the
movie A Quiet Place,
John Krasinski intended
for the character Regan
to be played by a deaf actress.
And the producers didn't
want to have a deaf actress.
They thought a hearing
actress would be acceptable.
He fought for that
because he wanted
to have an authentic
experience and to be
able to have an
actress who understood
what it felt like to be deaf
and how a deaf person would
interact.
And this is the reason why
it's important to have people
with disabilities
playing characters
who have disabilities
because it makes it
feel more real and authentic.
Well, I work in animation.
And the medium in
animation lends itself
to creating characters of all
types, especially characters
with disabilities.
And I really believe it's our
responsibility, especially
someone like me, a director or
writer, to acknowledge people
with disabilities and
put them in the stories
and in these films, because
that's the world we live in.
And I also believe that
through the power of animation,
a lot of it is for children.
So when you plant those
seeds and you basically
illuminate children
to see disabled people
as normal people--
and one of the things that
I find a little intriguing
is a lot of times the disabled
characters are perfect.
But what I really like is
when the disabled characters
have flaws because
that's humanity, right?
The flaws are what reflects
a real depth of a person,
because everyone who's disabled
isn't instantly a saint.
We all have our
goods and our bads.
So I think it's really,
really important to showcase
that depth and that humanity.
How do you feel your
success in Hollywood
has been received by the public
and by the disabled community?
I feel like when people
started taking notice
of me and my career, most people
didn't know that I'm actually
deaf in real life.
And people are typically
very surprised by that.
And they say things
like, oh, my gosh,
I had no idea that you're deaf.
You act really well.
And you're good enough
to be in the movies.
It's always shocking.
And I'm never sure
how I feel when
I receive responses like that.
In some sense, I'm
excited that I've
convinced them through my acting
skills to believe my character.
But in another sense, I feel
a little bit disappointed
and that I expect people
should know better.
A deaf character should
be played by a deaf actor
or a deaf actress.
But it doesn't happen that way.
A lot of people don't know that.
And it's really tough for me.
As far as the disability
community goes,
I feel that the success I've
had has helped them as well.
They're setting
their goals higher
and achieving those goals.
And from time to time, I
have fans reach out to me.
And they thank me for
instilling confidence in them.
They say when they see
themselves represented
in Hollywood on
the silver screen,
it's just saying that
we are smart enough.
We are talented.
We are good enough to do it.
We can be successful.
We can break
through the barriers
that have been set for us.
And that's not
just in Hollywood,
but in so many
other areas as well,
whether it's technology
or science or media.
And it's so inspiring.
Well, I am going to say about--
those people do love me.
And they do love my movie.
And I got many awards.
Awesome.
You know, I'll tell
you guys, when I first
was diagnosed with autism,
I was 40 years old.
So I didn't know
until much later
because my son has autism.
And my parents said,
well, he's just
like you when you were a kid.
And then as soon as I found
out, the people who represent me
said, you shouldn't
tell anybody.
It might be something that makes
people think you're difficult.
You know, all the cliches
and all the bad stereotypes.
And so I decided, no, I think
my work speaks for itself.
I think what I do
speaks for itself.
I'm going to be super
open about my diagnosis.
And I wanted to be a really
good example for my son
when he grows up.
And what that has turned
into is the autism community
has embraced me.
And I didn't even
know I was a part
of such a loving community.
I am now adding characters
with autism in my work.
And I'm definitely--
in animation,
I joke that 50% of the people
are on the autism spectrum,
but they just--
they've never been tested.
But anyways, what
stories would you
like to see told in
the future and by whom?
I would love to see
stories about deaf icons
and other icons in the
disability community.
We already know who they
are and where they are now,
but we don't know what
their backstory is.
We don't know what
their life was like
and what challenges and
obstacles they may have faced.
I would love to see those
icons who have so much
knowledge and experience and
the ability to tell a story
and to let us connect with
them and to do the disability
community justice.
I would really like to see that.
I would also love to see
stories from all over the world.
I would love to hear
about people's culture
and their language
and their traditions.
It's an opportunity for us
to all educate ourselves
and to learn from other people.
I am going to say the romantic
story and of course comedy,
drama, a superhero
with disabilities.
Superhero with disabilities--
that would be incredible, Zack.
Oh, my god.
I want to make that movie.
What does the future of
representation and inclusion
in Hollywood hopefully
look like to you?
I'm going to say
about the inclusion--
this is about everybody
with disabilities.
They really want to have
a really good chance.
I would love to see a lot more
opportunity for people like us.
I'd like to see more
movies that focus
on not only having a character
with a disability viewed
as sympathetic or less than
and more emphasis on characters
with disabilities
having more hope
and for the people
watching these movies
and shows to become educated
and to learn and to actually
listen.
I would love to see more
barriers broken down.
And I want to see
more opportunities
for people in the community
to reach their dreams.
I want to see diversity.
I want to see varying languages
and backgrounds and everything
on screen.
I want every person
to feel like they're
represented on the big
screen and for people
to feel that they could
even write their own stories
and share them with the world.
Great.
My dream in
representation would be so
that disability
characters are normal,
and they're in genre movies.
There's a Western, and one of
the characters is disabled.
And no one makes
a big deal of it.
It's just normal.
Or a sci-fi movie with someone,
one of the Fast and the Furious
movies, and someone's
in a wheelchair,
and it's normal, because
that's the real world.
So that's what I
would love to see.
What advice would you
like to give young people
with disabilities who want to
break into our beloved film
industry?
My advice for anyone who wants
to pursue acting as a career
is to have confidence
in yourself.
Get yourself out of
your comfort zone
and truly believe
that you can make it,
because no one's going
to do that for you.
You're the only one who
can do that for yourself.
I would encourage you to get
involved in acting classes,
whether it be in school
or in the community.
Maybe you could try Broadway
and see how different
that experience is with
the facial expressions
and the acting approaches.
Read as many books as you can.
Watch as many videos as
you can get your hands on.
Watch directors' cuts.
Watch different movies
that are out there
and see what it takes.
You really have to do
the work for yourself.
You could write
your own story even,
because writing your own story
allows you to say what you want
and to share your own
vision in your own career.
And you can decide what people
might want to know about you.
And that's what I think
is truly important.
Wow.
The advice I love to give
is no one's born a director.
You become a director, and
you grow into these roles
through hard work.
But it's-- I always say if I
can do it, anybody can do it.
I'm going to say
follow your heart.
Follow your dreams.
And someday, they will go big.
Wow.
That's beautiful.
So with talent like you
two, I think the future
is looking so bright.
I want to thank all
our guests today.
A huge thank you to the
Ruderman Foundation,
whose generous grant made
this program possible.
And finally, thank you, our
audience, for joining us today.
If you enjoyed this
program, please share it
with all your
friends and family.
It's posted on the Academy's
Facebook page and the Academy's
YouTube channel, as
well as on Oscars.org
where you can find some
fantastic additional content
under Extras.
So check it out.
And let's keep this
conversation going.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Bye.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
This program is made
possible in part
by the Ruderman Family
Foundation, which
promotes authentic
representation
in the entertainment industry
and full inclusion of people
with disabilities throughout
all sectors of society.
Additional support provided
by the Los Angeles County
Board of Supervisors through
the Los Angeles County
Department of Arts and Culture.
Special thanks-- Amanda Grazian
Caitlin Manocchio Charles
Mastropietro, Emily Simmonds,
Esther Tejano, Jack Jason,
Madison Heim-Jinivisian, Melissa
Zeigler, Rachel Javorsky,
Rene Ridinger, Shelley
Gottsagen, Stephanie Suski
and Trish Carland.